je me trouve actuellement devant la
salle agnès varda toujours au festival
de cannes c'est ici que aura lieu et
qu'a lieu la projection des talents
adami une série de courts métrages fait
pour mettre en avant de jeunes acteurs
qui débute on va aller à la rencontre
d'acteurs d'ile-de-france qui ont joué
dans le film de raphaël personnaz la
reine donc rafael persona bonjour dont
vous êtes le réalisateur de la reine
premièrement qu'est ce que ça vous fait
d'être ici à cannes pour pour présenter
votre court-métrage pour une première
réalisation c'est pas mal de se
retrouver là donc c'est très joyeux et
puis c'est surtout joyeux pour moi je
suis content pour les acteurs qu'ils
puissent voir le film ici avec un public
moi c'est tout tout est assez joyeux
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune secrétaire
d'état à la cohésion sociale qui est
envoyé sur le terrain pour se faire
élire aux législatives et qui va aller
dans un hôpital qu'il ya un hôpital qui
est en grève et sa visite va vraiment
pas se passer comme elle l'espérait
arrête tes conneries qu'elle essaye de
nous faire
convoquer les journalistes pour faire de
belles images c'est
l'organe on tue au perron
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu une découverte pour moi
puisque c'est la première fois donc je
prends tout avec avec émerveillement et
c'est assez agréable déjà de montrer le
film d'avoir des spectateurs autant de
spectateurs d'être tous réunis toute
l'équipe de tous les courts métrages non
je fends franchement cc c'est super de
rencontrer du monde 2
on est bien accompagné l'adami nous
accompagne merveilleusement là dedans
again on trouve fermo et des yvelines et
de versailles et plus précisément c'est
là bas qu'il a suivi son cursus pour en
arriver jusque là j'ai commencé à 15 ans
au conservatoire de versailles qui est
un super conservatoire ensuite je suis
allé dans une école privée à paris et
après j'ai fait trois ans au
conservatoire national et puis après
c'est une succession de rencontres
et voilà de 2,2 casting l'audition de de
travail ou même mois des projets que
j'ai mené moi même des mises en scène
c'est au total quatre films qui ont été
projetés lors de cette séance pour les
talents adami quatre films faits pour
mettre en avant des acteurs émergents